الكثير من الناس هناك الكثير من الناس
لا أستطيع احتواء الناس
تمكنت من احتواء الناس لكسر
النوافذ حطمت كل شيء في الداخل
من المنزل كسروا كل شيء بعد
تنصيب الرئيس الحالي لولا هو هذا
انخفض العدد كثيرًا هنا في
برازيليا حتى مع ذلك لا يزال لدينا
المعلومات التي كان بعضها
المخيم والمعلومات التي لدينا
هو أن العديد منهم اجتمعوا حقًا
في الواقع بشكل رئيسي من خلال الشبكات
الاجتماعية والمجدولة لذلك هذا
مظاهرة هنا نتذكر ذلك
يمكنهم تكوين هذه السلوكيات
الجرائم ضد دولة الديمقراطية
الكونغرس ليس لدينا حقًا
المعلومات في الوقت الحالي
يحدث نحن ننتظر
تلقي مقاطع الفيديو مباشرة من هناك
الفريق الذي نحن متخفون وأننا سوف
حاول إحضار المعلومات